fierce gun battles in the city of
Culiacan in Northwest Mexico security
forces and drug cartel gunmen fight it
out after the short-lived arrests of
Oviedo whose mommy he's the son of the
notorious drug cartel boss Joaquin
Guzman also known as El Chapo who's
serving a life sentence after
extradition to the United States the gun
battles went on for hours as army and
police forces came under increasing
attack vehicles were set ablaze for
terrified residents panic set in bodies
could be seen in the streets the capital
of Sinaloa state brought to a standstill
later in the day Mexico's Security
Minister laid out the sequence of events
today at 1530 hours a patrol composed of
30 elements of the National Guard and
sadena were conducting a routine patrol
in the tres Rios neighborhood of the
city of Culiacan Sinaloa when they were
attacked from a home Patrol personnel
repelled the assault and took control of
the house locating four occupants inside
during this action one of them was
identified as Oviedo Guzman Lopez this
led to several organized criminal groups
surrounding the house with a force
greater than that of the Patrol
likewise other related groups carried
out violent actions against citizens in
different parts of the city generating a
situation of Durazo said a decision was
ultimately made to release Guzman in
order to protect lives the state
government said it's working to restore
calm and called on everyone to stay off
the streets while Guzman is on the run
the latest fugitive in Mexico's
seemingly never-ending war on cocaine
traffickers Mohamed jim-jim al-jazeera